dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here we'll
start with a quick recap on metropolis
light transport and then discuss a cool
technique that builds on top of it if we
would like to see how digitally modeled
objects would look like in real life we
would create a 3d model of the desired
scene assign material models to the
objects within and use a photorealistic
rendering algorithm to finish the job it
simulates rays of light that connect the
camera to the light sources in the scene
and compute the flow of energy between
them initially after a few rays we'll
only have a rough idea on how the image
should look like therefore our initial
results will contain a substantial
amount of noise we can get rid of this
by simulating the paths of millions and
millions of rays that will eventually
clean up our image this process where a
noisy image gets clearer and clearer we
call convergence and the problem is that
this can take excruciating ly long even
up to hours to get a perfectly clear
image with the simple algorithms out
there we generate these light paths
randomly this technique we call path
tracing however in the scene that you
see here most random paths can't connect
the camera and the light source because
this wall is in the way obstructing many
of them light paths like these don't
contribute anything to our calculations
and are ultimately a waste of time and
resources after generating hundreds of
random light paths we finally found a
path that connects the camera with the
light source without any obstructions
when generating the next path it would
be a crime not to use this knowledge to
our advantage a technique called
metropolis light transport will make
sure to use this valuable knowledge and
upon finding a bright light path it will
explore other paths that are nearby to
have the best shot at creating valid
unobstructed connections if we have a
difficult scene at hand metropolis light
transport gives us way better results
than traditional completely random path
sampling techniques such as path tracing
this scene is extremely difficult in a
sense that the only source of light is
coming from the upper left and after the
light goes through multiple glass
spheres most of the light paths that we
generate will be invalid
as you can see this is a valiant effort
with random path tracing that yields
really dreadful results metropolis light
transport is extremely useful in these
cases and therefore should always be the
weapon of choice however it is more
expensive to compute and traditional
random sampling this means that if we
have an easy scene on our hands
this smart metropolis sampling doesn't
pay off and performs worse than a naive
technique in the same amount of time so
on easy scenes traditional random
sampling difficult scenes metropolis
sampling super simple super intuitive
but the million-dollar question is how
to mathematically formulate and measure
what an easy and what a difficult scene
is this problem is considered extremely
difficult and was left open in the
metropolis light transport paper in 2002
even if we knew what to look for we will
likely get an answer by creating a
converged image of the scene which
without the knowledge of what algorithm
to use may take up two days to complete
but if we have created the image it's
too late we would need this information
before we start this rendering process
this way we can choose the right
algorithm on the first try with this
technique that came more than 10 years
after the metropolis paper it is
possible to mathematically formalise and
quickly decide whether a scene is easy
or difficult the key insight is that in
a difficult scene we often experience
that a completely random ray is very
likely to be invalid this insight with
two other simple metrics gives us all
the knowledge we need to decide whether
a scene is easy or difficult and the
algorithm tells us what mixture of the
two sampling techniques we exactly need
to use to get beautiful images quickly
the more complex light transport
algorithms get the more efficient they
become but at the same time we are
wallowing in parameters that we need to
set up correctly to get adequate results
quickly this way we have an algorithm
that doesn't take any parameters you
just fire it up and forget about it like
a good employee it knows when to work
smart and when a dumped solution with a
lot of firepower is better and it was
tested on a variety of scenes and far
close to optimal settings implementing
this technique is remarkably easy
someone who is familiar with the basics
of light transport can do it in less
than half an hour thanks for watching
and for your generous support and I'll
see you next time